[Música]
há uma guerra silenciosa ocorrendo nesse
momento que vai determinar o nosso
futuro o sistema político quer ou não
quando você estão usando hoje o celular
sendo monitorado nas praças públicas
pelo próprio celular ou câmera de
vigilância fazendo compras na internet
planejando o que comer à noite pelo
aplicativo de celular
mas nessa guerra no ar disparos de
canhão e muito menos uma corrida para o
desenvolvimento de bombas nucleares mas
as suas razões
elas também tão ligado a diversos
conflitos político ideológico financeiro
de costumes
a cyber guerras com as guerras virtuais
elas me determinando nossas construções
sociais inclusive o nosso sistema
político inclusive a 1
há muitos países determinando o espaço
digital como seu território físico ou
seja da mesma maneira que o aro mara
terra e nesse espaço é imprescindível
que façamos uma reflexão mais profunda
aqui no brasil nós temos três esferas
governamentais que fazem parte da nossa
democracia que vêm do governo já também
a imprensa mas vocês provavelmente
concordar comigo que nas últimas
eleições e nos últimos anos nós já
estamos convivendo com a quinta força da
democracia que são as redes digitais nos
últimos anos eu tenho dedicado à minha
vida construir projetos para digitalizar
esse ambiente já atua em mais de 30
projetos cívicos em conjunto com 50
organizações políticas e mais de 400
políticos e nesse tempo ficou claro a
necessidade de digitalizar imediatamente
esse espaço
um dos projetos foi o voto legal onde
utilizamos
bota uma plataforma de boxe em 2016 mas
não para levar uma simplesmente uma
tecnologia mas para mudar o processo de
confiança entre o eleitor e os seus
candidatos assim como também desenvolver
um mandato aberto uma plataforma onde
levamos tecnologias de chat box para que
políticos pudessem escutar porque
atualmente eles também falam muito
nessas redes mas tem poucos canais de
escuta e de construção
um dos projetos que gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês foi desenvolvido
no instituto tecnologia eqüidade onde
trabalhamos com mais de 300 referências
no mundo com relação como esses para
esse novo espaço vem impactando a
democracia e algo está muito claro
nós precisamos urgentemente ocupar esse
espaço com novos processos democráticos
e para contar um pouco disso eu gostaria
de contar os fatos recentes na nossa
história que vem marcando como que
movimentos políticos estão surgindo
nessa rede
a primavera árabe em 2010 que foram à
reunião de diversos povos de língua
árabe que foram às ruas gritarem por uma
democracia real
elas foram às ruas para pedir eleições
foram às ruas para derrubar ditadores
ao mesmo tempo logo depois tivemos em
2011 nos estados unidos
o movimento o pai onde as pessoas foram
às ruas para brigar contra as
desigualdades econômicas e financeiras
ali existentes
o grito também era sobre uma democracia
uma democracia que é um poder que o povo
pode exercer
nós tivemos aqui no brasil a jornada de
junho que foram uma manifestações
inicialmente que surgir em são paulo
para protestar contra o aumento de
tarifas de 20 centavos mas que
rapidamente se espalhou pelo brasil
inteiro por diversos outros motivos
nós temos agora o movimento de coletes
amarelos na frança que vem sendo 11
rússia da população vendo um governo
realizando diversas reformas sem que a
população seja escutada
é algo incrível para que nós possamos
refletir dentro desses movimentos são
redes que aparentemente não têm um líder
formal e nós do mundo de tecnologia
estamos usando um termo chamado utopia
cibernética a determinar esses
movimentos para estudar eles onde a
comunicação online se ela parece
emancipatória que os oprimidos agora tem
vozes lugar dos professores ao mesmo
tempo que tudo isso ocorre
nós estamos visualizando um outro
movimento que a distopia cibernética
onde é possível visualizar um aumento de
desinformação de manipulação inclusive
de extremismo eo radicalismo tem pra
falar um pouco mais disso é necessário
que nós possamos refletir também da
nossa história um pouco com relação a
alguns acontecimentos históricos por
exemplo ira em 2010 as suas usinas de
enriquecimento de urânio foram atacadas
por um vírus de computador
elas começaram a girar mais rápido e foi
depois de algumas investigações
comprovado que um vírus nessa mesma rede
contaminou diversos computadores no
mundo e só só foi ativo ali muitos
especialistas de segurança eles afirmam
que esse foi um grande primeiro saiba
ataque existentes na nossa história
assim como na ucrânia durante o inverno
com baixas temperaturas os seus sistemas
de energia eles foram desligados
completamente e depois de uma
investigação também ficou comprovado que
foi um vírus de computador que realizou
esse ataque
recentemente israel filmou um ataque de
drone na faixa de gaza
comentando já realizando um ataque
militar porque ali havia um hackers que
estavam atacando suas estruturas físicas
mas o que eu quero colocar aqui pra
vocês é que há uma infraestrutura
digital uma rede sendo utilizado para a
realização de movimentos políticos tão
importantes
atualmente pela briga da nossa
democracia assim como nós estamos vendo
essa cyber guerra acontecendo dentro de
si mesmo espaço e pra isso eu quero
compartilhar com vocês uma preocupação
enorme que eu tenho com relação ao
terrorismo de baixo custo
alguns de vocês talvez vão se lembrar de
uma expressão que já usamos muito em
escolas em adolescentes como cyber
bullying mas o terrorismo de baixo custo
é algo perigoso isso e vem sendo uma
tática utilizada de maneira recorrente é
onde pessoas divulgam dados pessoais de
algumas alguma pessoa um alvo esperando
contar com a violência que nós humanos
algum grupo porque nós somos seres
tribais
nós precisamos da política para
enfrentar isso
eu quero contar uma história horrível
pra vocês que da fabiana de jesus que
ela morreu por uma notícia falsa no
guarujá
depois de um post no facebook de um
dizendo a uma mulher seqüestrando
crianças no guarujá alguma pessoa viu
aquilo e sem estudar sem se aprofundar
sem conhecimento gerou tamanha violência
e isso parece um caso isolado mas vem
acontecendo de uma maneira cada vez mais
recorrente contra políticos jornalistas
ativistas
essa é uma tática que vem sendo
empregada e que é muito importante que
tenhamos noção sobre isso e eu quero
colocar aqui pra vocês uma provocação
que o vírus do óleo se ao mesmo tempo
vírus de computador que eram
transmitidos até pouco tempo entre
computadores que eram infectados
realizar alguma ação específica agora
talvez os humanos seja sem
infraestrutura com base no ódio
proliferando mensagens muitas vezes sem
conhecimento estão divulgando
informações que podem atingir alguém é
grande
a grande questão que eu acredito que há
apenas duas maneiras
atualmente a gente combater isso dentro
das nossas democracias
a primeira delas que eu gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês
a divisão de poderes dentro dos espaços
democráticos votar cada dois anos já não
é mais a grande maneira de participar da
democracia
isso parece óbvio mas quando as redes
digitais
elas aparecem como uma grande força fica
evidente que a gente tem que fomentar
isso cada vez mais os nossos líderes
locais assim como não podemos abandonar
para discutir política sobre evidências
fundamentadas
nós devemos investir em educação em
políticas públicas de formação não
podemos fazer política sem construir um
conhecimento prévio sem conhecimento nós
somos manipulados para vocês terem uma
ideia do momento que nós vivemos com
relação à frustração que nós vivemos no
nosso sistema político atual
apenas 34% dos brasileiros estão
satisfeitos com nosso sistema
democrático da maneira com que ele
funciona assim como em 2018
nós batemos um recorde mais de 30% das
pessoas que poderiam votar não foram às
urnas votaram branco ou nulo
algo realmente errado acontecendo
e pra isso é importante uma reflexão
sobre medo e angústia na política o
melhor coragem quando nós temos medo de
algo
nós nos organizamos montamos um coletivo
digamos vamos pra cima né dentro da
política quando há um sentimento de
angústia é quando nós ficamos
paralisados não acreditamos em mais nada
é quando vem aquele sentimento de
aversão com relação a tudo que existe
atualmente é quando nós desistimos e
provavelmente estamos mais suscetíveis à
manipulação ao vírus do ódio
provavelmente como a gente ouve dizer
sobre as bolhas nós somos vulneráveis
dentro das nossas próprias realidades
sem saber escutar
nós não vamos ter condições de construir
caminhos democráticos e pra isso eu
gostaria de falar pra vocês e contar
como que medos e angústias vem se
transformando em dados
atualmente como já comentei com vocês
esses medos e angústias hoje são dados
dentro de diversas plataformas
estruturas digitais de alguns agentes
que já estão comprimindo compreendendo
eles muito bem nós que trabalhamos com
tecnologia erramos feio nos últimos 20
anos
com relação ao desenvolvimento de
algumas disciplinas de tecnologia
se por um lado foi benéfica e trouxe
várias oportunidades para nós
nós desenvolvemos disciplina como por
exemplo a capital logia nos últimos 20
anos estudamos isso nas universidades
que a ciência de persuação com
tecnologia
atualmente o que nós buscamos em
tecnologia não é mais o saneamento o
dinheiro dos usuários mas atenção as
grandes plataformas hoje elas são
gratuitas
estão criando modelos de negócios
complexos que em diversos momentos
parecem é ter uma boa oportunidade como
entregar informações em conhecimento
mas quando isso é dito sobre o olhar de
política vem demonstrando um grande
perigo
o que eu quero colocar pra vocês por
exemplo é o youtube youtube hoje a maior
plataforma de vídeo online tem um
impacto fantástico no aprendizado
distribuição de conhecimento mas são
dois bilhões de usuários
vocês terem uma ideia é um número maior
do que os fiéis da igreja católica no
mundo nunca teve redes tão grandes no
mundo dessa maneira mas os algoritmos
hoje determinam 70% do que nós
assistimos isso significa que a maioria
dos usuários que entram lá 30 por cento
escolhem o que vão ver e dali em diante
nós recebemos o que o algoritmo
determinou que vamos aprender
só para vocês terem uma idéia uma
conferência recente sobre terra plana
uma um instituto vai fazer uma pesquisa
e perguntaram por que você acredita que
a terra é plana de 30 pessoas 29
afirmaram depois de ver um vídeo na
internet
os algoritmos eles vêm criando dentro
dessa economia da atenção algumas
divisões profundas
quando o assunto é política nós estamos
cada vez mais entrando em uma bolha de
aversão diz não acreditar mais em não
querer mais falar com quem pensa
diferente de nós estamos cometendo um
grande erro tendo nesse processo
na minha opinião e pra isso em 2018
nicho tem um jeito idade nós
desenvolvemos um material com mais de
300 referências entrevistas para mapear
como que as redes sociais e o dinheiro
vem determinando conteúdo legítimo
ilegítimo e conseqüentemente como que
isso vem determinando intenções de voto
mas além de montar esse mapa o nosso
trabalho foi também desenvolver pontos
de alavancagem ou seja ações concretas
para que em 2020 possamos ter uma
eleição com mais informação legítima do
que informação legítima e isso envolve
propostas desde plataformas digitais
colocarem transparência nos seus
algoritmos com relação à publicidade de
política a adoção de tecnologia de
análise de dados de redes sociais pelas
universidades brasileiras
até porque a grande maioria dessas redes
digitais não são criadas no brasil assim
como ensino maior sobre tecnologia e
novos processos democráticos dentro das
nossas escolas mas apesar de todas essas
propostas
eu não acredito que elas vão funcionar a
implementação de leis de proteção de
dados pessoais debatendo congresso ética
da inteligência artificial tudo isso faz
sentido mas não faz o mínimo sentido se
todos vocês não começarem a atuar também
com relação a isso a participar mais da
democracia
não há melhor tecnologia disponível para
nós hoje do que a conversa com quem
pensa diferente de nós
eu sou otimista nos últimos anos a
tecnologia já vem determinando por
exemplo com o movimento de navios
abertos uma transparência dos governos
há dez anos atrás não existiam
plataformas digitais pra gente contestar
como o governo contratava
como gastar o seu dinheiro assim como
diversas tecnologias vem sendo empregado
por um controle social nos últimos anos
e agora a gente já começa a ver diversos
outros movimentos como guigó vittek que
eu quero colocar aqui pra vocês é que
vocês participem mais da democracia mas
não apenas divulgando o que outros estão
pedindo mas criando novos processos de
participação porque isso é possível
obrigado
[Aplausos]